er kommt zu einer neuen sendung im
rahmen des hinaus ganz freiheitsbegriff
1786 bis 1800 rekonstruktion einer
debatte
heute soll es manuel friedrich schiller
gehen und um die frage was schiller zu
dieser debatte eingetragen hat ich sage
jetzt erst mal ein bisschen was zu
friedrich schillers das ist ein sehr
realistisches gemälde schiller hat
verschiedene geschrieben erst bekannt
als dramatiker habe hat auch einige
philosophische gedichte geschrieben
darunter vielleicht das bekannteste werk
mit dem titel über angeboten würde
von 1793 und auch noch möchte ich jetzt
noch wählen obwohl wir jetzt diesem
seminar darauf nicht mehr eingehen
werden seine schrift oder seine briefe
genauer gesagt über die ästhetische
erziehung des menschen die am ende
einige jahre lang teils verstreut
erschien und dann gesammelt zu ende
gebracht wurden 17 95
jetzt sagen sie ein bisschen was zu
schillers leben und werk und
geistesgeschichtliche bedeutung schiller
studierte zunächst in stuttgart auf der
hohen karlsschule medizin als medizin
arzt muss man sich das vorstellen das
war es ein bisschen auch soldatisch
geprägt er war in einer art kaserne auch
und er befasste sich mit dem leiden
seele problem wie man es heute sagen
könnte schrieb nämlich veröffentlichte
1780 seine medizinische dissertation die
den titel trug versuch über den
zusammenhang der tierischen natur und
des menschen also wir sehen wir schon es
geht um eine gewisse verhältnismäßigkeit
zwischen anleihen und seele
es geht hier um die tierischen natur wie
wir hier sehen
und die geistige diese zusammenhänge der
ist des schülers gesamtes denken
sehr sehr zentral ja dann aufgrund von
politischen differenzen die er mit
seinem gefährt kam eugen hatte
das war der herzog kam und gehen unter
dem schiller eben diente der die
freiheit und seiner bürger württemberg
waren stark einschränkte flüchtete er
ins porsche mannheim wo er dann als
dramatiker ritte und sie kennen
sicherlich alle die räuber wo er für die
freiheit plädierte und das hat natürlich
seine landesherrn und anderen landes
während dieser zeit damals nicht so gut
gefallen
im weiteren verlauf wurde er wie viele
andere diese mitglieder dieser denker
der nach kantischen freiheitspartei
professur in jena jeder war der
anziehungspunkte damaligen geistigen
tradition auch der literarischen muss
man dazu sagen und er befasste sich dann
ab 1791 da ist das jahr in dem umkreis
kants kritik der urteilskraft erschien
sein wichtigstes ästhetisches werk
intensiven mit ganz viel sie vor allem
mit seiner ästhetik und er wirkte wie
wir alle diesen dann gehen jena und
bitte auch in weimar sehr sehr stark als
dramatiker wallenstein und wie sie alle
heißen sein werk ist hier natürlich viel
berühmter geworden ist als alles wieder
so wie wurde sitzt aber nicht nur
schüler als wieder so zu denken sondern
genauer gesagt schiller als
freiheitsdenker als genauer gesagt
willensfreiheit sticker so wir haben ein
paar leute fragen die diese
beschäftigung strukturieren soll
er ist mein neffe dritte inwiefern
kritisiert schüler kann es
freiheitsbegriff immer am anfang dieser
debatte steht eine gewisse abgrenzung
von ganz freiheitsbegriff und dann
findet eine individuelle
auseinandersetzung damit statt
die wird strukturiert durch die
rezeption von reinartz bilanz begriffe
die wir in der letzten sitzung
diskutiert hat nicht nach oben rechts
und links also wie krank
und zum schluss wie viel ist inwiefern
ist schillers ästhetischer
freiheitsbegriff erzeugen
da soll die abschließende frage der
heutigen sitzung bevor ich jetzt auch
schüler eingehen sollten wir uns noch
mal kurz geht karl bernhard reinhold
befassen
hier in seinen briefen über die kante
philosophie diese debatte für schiller
entscheidend vorangebracht hat
reinhold strebt dort in diesen briefen
alle bisherigen philosophischen system
und alle metaphysischen gegriffen ohne
ausnahme stehen mit einem richtigen
begriffe von der freiheit im geraden
widerspruch auch die kritik der reinen
und der praktischen vernunft hat diesen
begriff nur angedeutet keineswegs aber
mit denjenigen merkmal aufgestellt
diesen gegenstand von allen land
unterscheiden
sie hat eine erklärung davon geben
können weil sie dieselben uhr jetzt
möglich machen konnte und musste den
übergang von dieser nur fahren
möglichkeit regel kein ist durch die mal
schnell gehörigen schriften der freunde
der kritischen philosophie viel mehr
erschwert als erleichtert worden als wir
sehen jetzt hier
es geht darum dass wir es hier noch in
einem vorstadium abend der freiheit
begrifflichen entwicklung ja das war die
möglichkeit kann hat das stimmt in der
kritik der ein von uns bestimmt das
hatte die möglichkeit aufgezeigt nach
oben rechts wieder blinkt rheins in
dieser jeweiligen sitzen die
wirklichkeit sagt ihr zwar bekannt nicht
aufgezeigt da widerspreche ich eben
nämlich hier hat das doch versucht die
kritik der praktischen vernunft
damaligen rechtsauslegung der
praktischen freiheit da ist hat auch
schon ein bisschen stärker
er spricht von fakten der vernunft das
ist doch die wirklichkeit jeden fall
sagt reinhardt hier muss noch viel
gemacht werden und der richtige begriff
der freiheit der muss erst noch
entwickelt werden und jetzt schauen wir
mal wie von auch schüler an diesen
richtigen freiheitsbegriff herangeht in
die taten auch wirklich entwickeln kann
er hat noch ein zitat das er
anderen sollten sagt die der bewusst
sein sohn aber vielleicht geben darum
der spekulation bisschen sofern gelegene
unterscheidung zwischen der
unwillkürlichen forderung und der
willkürlichen beschädigungen in einer
tollen stadt nicht öffnet den weg zu
diesem übergang von der möglichkeit zur
wirklichkeit den ich bereits
zurückgelegt zu haben glaube wenn ich
mit dem willen jetzt kommt das
entscheidende total also das vermögen
der personen sinken
ich denke ich selbst zur wirklichen
befriedigung oder nicht befriedigung
einer forderung des begehrens zu
bestellen die haben wir jetzt als ein
ganz zentrales zitat also der viele das
wird er will einmal richtig definiert
bei kant war der wille januar eine
praktische fünfte frei
das vermögen der person auto wer so
kommt der zentraler zentrum jetzt hier
ist es sich selbst so wirklich und wird
lediglich jetzt weniger oder nicht
befriedigen einer verordnung des
begehrens bestimmt als befriedigung oder
nicht befriedigen
das gibt diese zwei möglichkeiten die
wir hier wiedersehen
das ist das prinzip billig was wir hier
wieder haben und auch noch mal wichtig
sich selbst dieses autonomen moment und
eben bezogen auf first nations das
begehren ja soviel dazu und jetzt lösen
wir so langsam aber sicher auf nach
einer heute übergehen ich möchte noch
ein zitat von rheine auf schüler
übergehen ein zitat man kann heute sagen
die kantischen schriften haben den
bestimmten begriff der das logische
lesen gehen sie halt nur erst
vorbereitet keineswegs schon geliefert
also es geht darum dass die nur
expositionen sind und aber nicht
wirklich aus entwickelt sind und diese
entwicklung des willens in seinem
wirklichen moment in einer überzeugenden
willens theorie dass er 30 gramm
und wir werden jetzt gleich sind das
das auch versucht es nochmal seien zwei
schriften und jetzt geben also in diese
schriften über handeln würde direkt 3 so
jetzt sagt schiller hier folgen dass es
den menschen zwar aufgegeben einige
übereinstimmungen zwischen seinen beinen
naturen natur muss aber schöner immer
sagen es die vernunft und eben die
sinnlichkeit also die biologische
triebhafte natur und die vernunft zu
stiften immer ein harmonisches ganz sein
wird mit seiner vollständigen ganzen
menschheit zu hand hier sehen sie
wiederum verweist auf seine dissertation
die er dieses leib seele problem hatte
auch hier in der die situation war die
frage schon hier können wir das geistige
mit dem natürlichen verbinden zu einer
harmonischen einheit aber diese
charakter schönheit so spricht er jetzt
mit ihm kann dieser vollständigen ganzen
menschheit die erste frucht sei
normalität ist los einigen de welche
gemäss zu werden er mit anhaltender
wachsamkeit streben aber die aber alle
anstrengungen nicht ganz erreichen kann
idee erkannt eine transsexualität
perspektive also wir können da nur ihnen
denken aber wirklich erlangen können wir
sie nicht der grund warum er ist nicht
kann ist die unveränderliche einrichtung
seiner natur das sind die physischen
bedingungen des daseins selbst die damen
verhindern
schiller hat muss man dazu sagen war
zeit seines lebens immer sehr gründlich
vor allem am ende
ich darf ein sehr gutes buch von rüdiger
safranski hinweisen schiller oder die
erfindung des sozialismus besonders die
ersten seiten zensierte teilen dieser
franz gehen beschreiben wie krank sie
das körper eigentlich war und wir in
diesem kranken körper der praxis sehr
viel wie dahin noch so viel geistiges am
ende entstehen und wurden konnte also
schiller wusste genau diesen
journalismus an seinem eigenen leiden zu
spüren zwischen den fällige endlichkeit
seines körpers und geistiger ideale f
seiner berge weiter sagt schiller
nämlich seine existenz in der sinne welt
die von natur bedingungen abhängt
sicherzustellen und musste der mensch
daher als ein wesen das sich nach
willigen
kann er seine erhaltung selbst zu sorgen
hat zur handlung vermocht werden wodurch
jede physischen bedingung sein start als
erfüllen und werden sie aufgehoben sind
wiederhergestellt werden können also der
mensch braucht erstmal eine basis auf
der dann handeln kann
das ist so die grundlage weiter sagt
schiller obgleich aber die natur dieses
sorge die mir diese in ihrem wg
tamilischen erzeugt und ganz allein über
sich nimmt ihm selbst immer geben müsste
so durfte doch befriedigung eines zu
dringe bedürfnisses wo es sein und seine
seines geschlechts ganz nah sein gilt
seiner ungewissen einsicht nicht vor
anvertraut werden
sie zog also diese angelegenheit die dem
inhalte nach ihr geht gehört auch der
vormachen dieselbe indem sie die
bestimmung der willkür notwendigkeit
liegt sollen stelle natur trägt er
nichts anderes ist als eine
notwendigkeit durch das medium die
empfindung also jetzt versucht stellt
diese natur diese zweifache natur des
menschen ein bisschen genauer zu
beschreiben die natur trieb bestimmt das
abfindungs vermögen durch die gekoppelte
markt von stolz und vergnügen sich
schmerzvoll befriedigung fordert durch
wirken sie findet das sind also zwei
anreize einmal weg lenkung ablenkung und
einmal in lenkung schmerz und vergnügen
das die antriebskräfte der natur
die motive der natur kann damit auf sah
die zweige stimmungs könnte da eine
natur notwendigkeit nichts abzudecken
ist so muss auch der mensch seine
freiheit ungeachtet empfinden was die
natur finden lassen will
und je nachdem die empfindung schmerz
und lust ist so muss bei ihm ebenso
unabänderlich verabscheuen oder begierde
erfolgen in diesem punkt steht er dem
tier vollkommen gleich und der staub
mutigste stärker fühlten oder eben so
empfindlich und verabschiedungen ebenso
lebhaft als der gewonnen zu seinen füßen
also das ist eine grundtendenz allen
lebens selbst wenn wir frei sind
das wird diese verschiedenen strömungen
in uns selbst dass durch diese ganz
abgeklärt denker und der wurm de - die
kreatur die haben in sich immer noch
diese natur notwendigkeit die sie
versprochen jetzt aber fängt der große
unterschied an
auf die idee und verabscheue erfolgt bei
der tiere den form geben so notwendig
handlung als begierden auf empfindung
und empfindung aus den äußeren haltung
erfolgt es ist hier eine stetige
fortlaufende kette wieder regen dieser
kette die das kettenglied notwendigkeit
in einen anderen kreis bei den menschen
ist noch eine instanz mehr nämlich den
viele als ein übersinnliches vermögen
wieder dem gesetz die natur nachdem der
vernunft so darauf ist dass sie nicht
vollkommen freie wahl bliebe ich jetzt
wieder nach diesem oder nachrichten das
tier muss streben den schmerzlos dass
sein der mensch kann sich entschließen
dienst und jetzt verweist hier schiller
am ende auf die definition des willens
im zweiten band von reinholz brief über
die chaotischen philosophie gerade
dieser stelle die sehr sehr zentrale
sind also hier bei den menschen ist noch
eine andere instanz an distanz mehr
nämlich der wille übersinnliches
vermögen also nicht der natur gehörig
zugeschrieben aber auch nicht der
vernunft das ist auch ganz wichtig die
rede ist weder natur noch sondern das
fasten zu stellen er sagte dass weder
dem gesetz der natur nach dem gesetz der
vernunft erster zwischen verschieden
er hat die freie wahl zwischen bei
das tier muss streben ist also eine
notwendigkeit zusammenhalt eingelassen
der mensch kann hat frei war wieder sich
entschließen ihnen sogar wir den schluss
dass die willkür wieder
also wir sehen hier der mensch der steht
aus dieser kette heraus in kanada zu
verhalten
am ende dieses interessante bezug zur
ein ort den wir schon
zu genügen der letzten sitzung behandelt
hatten der wille des menschen ist seine
partner begriff schiller weiter auch
dann wenn man auf seine moralischen
braucht nicht achtet und kannte hatte
eben vor allem auf den moralischen
braucht die hre eine praktische vernunft
schon der bloße wille sagte schiller
er hebt den menschen über die tier hat
die moralische eben hin zu gott hat er
muss aber jene die die tat zuvor
verlassen haben er sich dieser nähern
kann
da ist es kein geringer schritt zur
moralischen frage des willens
durchbrechung der natur notwendigkeit in
sich auch in gleichgültigen ding den
bloßen die gesetzgebung sagt schiller
weiter natur hat bestand bis zu wählen
wo sich entdeckt und die vernünftige
anfängt der wille steht hier zwischen
allen gerichtsbarkeiten und es kommt
ganz auf ihn selbst an von welcher
gerichtsbarkeit jedes gesetz empfangen
will
aber er steht nicht im gleichen
verhältnis gegen wurde als naturkraft
piste gegen die einigen wie gegen die
antritt frei das heißt er muss ich
wieder zu dieser noch zu jeder schlagen
aber er ist nicht frei als moralische
kraft das heißt er soll sich zu der
vernünftigen schlagen gebunden ist ja
keine aber verbunden ist er dem gesetz
der vernunft gebraucht als seine
freiheit wirklich wenn er gar nicht der
vernunft widersprechend handelt aber er
gebraucht sie unwürdig weil er
ungeachtet seiner freiheit doch nur
innerhalb der natur steht bleibt unsere
operation des betriebs gar keine
realität zu tun denn aus plädierte
wollen heißen wo verständlich das halte
ich für das zdf als zitat von schiller
wieder hier stehen zwischen diesem
mittelposition
es kommt auf die ihnen selbst an
autonomie aber nicht im gleichen feld
ist interessant es gibt eine art
trier er muss sich nicht weder für das
eine das andere entscheiden habe er soll
das heißt er hat keine forderung die der
noch dazu kommt sich zu der vernünftigen
sinnlichkeit schlagen und dieses zitat
finde ich auch sehr sehr schön gebunden
ist dann keine gesetzmäßigkeit aber
verbunden ist er denke setzt der
vernunft gebunden ist aber verboten ist
der sittlichkeit und damit kann jetzt
schüler dieses problem das in fatalismus
eigentlich ziemlich gut lösen
ja wo es ist nicht dem sittengesetz
folgen er ist auch freiwillig tätigen
gesetz aber erst sollte es
er muss wissen der mensch die person was
sie damit tot wenn sie nicht der
vernunft forderung gehört als er
gebraucht die freiheit wirklich auch
wenn sie der widersprechen sprich böse
handelt aber gebraucht würde
weil er eben nur in seinen trieben
stehen bleiben und sich nicht erhebt
darum dass wenn ihr jetzt sehr schönes
zitat aus europa ein heute noch ein
stück weit hinausgeht
warum zitat von schiller hier jetzt der
direkte bezug man lese über diese
materie die alle aufmerksamkeit würdige
theorie des willens
im zweiten teil der einheimischen briefe
also hier bezieht sich auf reinhold und
der damaligen zeit war das nicht so
üblich dass man seine quellen korrekt
angegeben hat
so findest es schüler durchaus hoch
anzurechnen dass ich hier darauf
beziehen
genau das hat mir schon ein bisschen und
jetzt kommt er am schluss noch so ein
bisschen auf die schönheit zu sprechen
dass es auch eine frage die wir noch
hier kurz diese behandeln wollen bei
schiller steht der alles immer auch im
zusammenhang mit dem hilft die schönheit
der ästhetik und jetzt interpretiert
schilder diese freiheits theorie auch
ästhetische einstimmung mit dem vernunft
gesetzt sagt schiller ist also perfekte
nicht anders möglich
als sich ein widerspruch mit den
feuerung der natur und da die natur
ihrer forderung aus zeitlichen gründen
die zurückgehen fröhlich auf ihrer seite
alles ist gleich
wie auch die plötzlichen an ihrem
verhalten mag das ist hier keine
zusammen stimmung zwischen neigung und
pflegt segen vernünftigen sinnlichkeit
möglich so kann der mensch hier nicht
mit seiner ganzen harmonierenden natur
sind aus schließungs weise nur mit
seiner vernünftigen handelt als in
diesen fällen auch nicht moralisch schön
weil an der schönheit handlung auch die
neigung notwendig teilnehmen muss die
hier vielmehr wieder streitet er handelt
aber woran stross alle stars und das
allein kurses von seiner überlegenheit
des hörens über das zeugnis
also ich möchte hier auch noch mal ganz
kurz reingehen text und schaue das jetzt
hier also es kommt hier der begriff des
moralisch schönen spiel und das ist eben
diese sammelt stimmung zwischen vernunft
und sinnlichkeit das ist das moralisch
schöne diese ganze harmonierende natur
an schüler geht es um die harmonie und
wenn eben aus schließungs weise der
vernünftigen gehandelt wird dann ist es
nicht schön war schön aber immerhin nur
eine stross aber für schiller ist
moralisch schön doch über moralisch
großes thema weil da noch eine
vereinheitlichung leistung mit erreicht
wurde
jetzt gehen wir noch ein bisschen weiter
weil der würde reise führt sich der
kreis das ist jetzt eben gerade die
moralische größe diese würde fühlt sich
der greisen körper als herrscher auf
denn hier hat er seine selbstständigkeit
gegen gibt die deutschen trieb zu
behaupten der ohne ihn so an jungen
schreitet und sich sagen ja auch gerne
ziehen möchte es konnte anmut bei der
anmut hingegen begehrt die liberalität
es ist der die natur eingesetzt und
keine widerstand zu besiegen findet
nachsicht verdient aber mutige hause und
strenge kann nur die besetzung
rechtfertigen bei der würde als jetzt
wird sich der geist in seinem körper
als herrscher auf hier hat er seine
selbständigkeit gegen dem gebieterischen
trieben zu behaupten der ohne ihn zur
handlung schreiben und sich seine mich
auch gerne ziehen möchte weil der anmut
hingegen regiert die liberalität aleris
ist der die handlungen natur eine
handlung setzt und keinen widerstand wie
wir schon gesehen haben zu wissen findet
also hier sehen wir jetzt ganz klar das
ist ein unterschied gibt bei schiller
zwischen der würde da dritte geist als
herrscher auf und er kann mut damit die
qualität also mit freiheit
da haben wir diese harmonie deswegen ist
schildert die anmut hier inszeniert
dieser moralischen schönheit zu
verstehen und die würde es in diese
moralische größe alter schiller wird aus
ästhetischen gründen die anmut klar
bevorzugen so zum schluss noch dieses
zitat und liegt als in der freiheit der
willkürlichen bewegungen würde in der
beherrschung der unwillkürlichen die
anmut lässt die natur dar wo sie die
befehle des geistes ausrichtet ein
schein von freiwilligkeit die würde
hingegen und der ist da wo sie erst mit
dem geist überall betrieb anfängt zu
handeln und sich herausnimmt das amt des
willens zu greifen
da auch der wille keine intelligenz also
keine absicht sondern muss durch die
nachdrücklichsten widerstände seine
selbständigkeit also beweisen
wohin die interviewer anfängt und die
sinnlichkeit in folge dass dafür keine
strenge man muss intelligenz das heißt
dies ist mit wenigen worten das gesetz
so das verhältnis altena tone menschen
so wie es in der erscheinung sich
darstellen also hier nochmal die anmut
die definition der anmut ist die frage
wie kündigung würde es die beherrschung
schiller kritisiert immer moderierte
beherrschung
wohin geht es ohne harmonische
verhältnisse dem islam nicht kompatibel
sind und die anmut lässt die natur einen
schein von freiwilligkeit
sie fasst die natur als etwas aufpassen
in sich ja eine tendenz zur freiheit hat
und deswegen auch mit ihren er verbunden
ist als es die würde tut die die natur
unterwirft und eben über sie beherrscht
ist dieses währungsverhältnis was
schiller nicht ästhetisch billigen
möchte das ist interessant das
grundmotiv von schillers gesamtwerk ja
dabei möchte ich jetzt eigentlich
beenden lassen
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein zitat da
die würde und anmut ihre verschiedenen
gebiete haben worin sie sich äußern zu
schließen sie einen anderen derselben
kannst du ja den selben zustand einer
person nicht aus fehlen jetzt nur die
anmut von der die würde ihre
beglaubigung und nur die würde von der
die an ihren wert empfängt die immer bei
schiller versucht am ende zu
synthetisieren
als sie zu vereinigen sie verschiedene
gebiete haben in der person und sie
ergänzen sich ja beglaubigung und wert
also die moral bekommt die die anmut
bekommt für das würde die offizielle
lizenz seit die rechtfertigung und die
würde die moral bekommt ihren wert mit
könnte auch sagen ihren glanz verlieren
also beide verhalten sich sein
komplementär ergänzen sich in schöner
abend
das ist so ein schönes fazit seiner
ausführung über ein model würde was ich
damit sagen wollte es geht schon an
diesem werk nicht so sehr nur in
ästhetischer verhältnisse auch nicht um
moral sondern letztendlich um die
einheit des menschen aber auch natürlich
zentrale wo die freiheit und hier spielt
der wille wie wir gesehen haben eine
ganz ganz große rolle weswegen sich auch
schiller wirklich als ein wichtiger
denker dieser nach kantischen falls
debatte folgen 1786 bis 18
erwiesen hat ich wünsche jetzt allen
meinen teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmern
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern alles gute
und wir sehen uns in der nächsten
sitzung